big bucks retailer target vows to
increase its hourly wages to more than
double the national minimum by the end
of 2020 target's CEO announced the
company will boost wages to $15 an hour
over the next three years he says the
increase will affect thousands of it's
more than 300 thousand employees and
more than 100 thousand seasonal workers
the move comes as target works to pull
itself out of a sales slump CBS News
financial contributor Mellody Hobson is
in Chicago melody good morning good
morning first question I have for you
what will it mean for the cost of goods
at Target will they go up as well well
interestingly what the company is saying
is that prices are actually going to go
down not up and we're seeing this in a
lot of stories in retail right now we're
lowering prices as a priority we saw it
with Amazon when they purchased Whole
Foods so they're saying they won't go up
in fact they will go out and go down and
to make up for that difference what they
need is scale more sales so raising it
to $11 an hour melody how does it
compare to their competitors it would
rank them number five amongst the
big-box retailers with Costco leading
the charge at $13 an hour
Nordstrom's behind them Lowe's and then
home depot than Target it puts them in a
pretty strong competitive position when
you think about of retailers who have
five hundred million dollars in sales or
more the average hourly rate is around
$9 are we simply going to see across the
board most companies a push towards
towards but not there $15 an hour
I think the the bottom line I don't know
if it's 15 or 14 or 13 but the bottom
line is these wages are going up one
reason is because we're at virtually
full employment at four point three
percent for our unemployment rate the
other thing is at this level it's not
necessarily so hard to get the people
it's hard to keep them these are
entry-level jobs where someone will
leave for a 25 cent per hour increase
and go to another employer they also
want to try to see a career path they
need a way to keep these people in these
jobs so telegraphing that they're going
to 15 dollars by 2020 I think is a way
of suggesting
with us there's a way of making more
money and having a career PAP here
tending for a better workforce excuse me
an incentive for a better workforce
absolutely and also to go up against the
online retailers their asset which many
see as their liability is the store they
want to make sure when you walk in that
store you're not lost you can get what
you need and you can get a good customer
experience and there's a direct
correlation between a happy employee and
higher customer satisfaction yeah that
would make sense but there's sometimes
pushback to raising the minimum wage
what's the downside melody as some see
it
the downside is some see it is that it
leads to further unemployment because
companies can't afford it but this train
has left the station and the federal
minimum wage is $7.25 we're talking
about $11 going to 15 we've seen some
states like Washington and Massachusetts
already go to 11 I mentioned Costco pays
$13 an hour people recognize you have to
pay more alright Mellody Hobson always
good to see you thank you very much for
joining us from Chicago this morning